voilà madame la ministre donc nous
continuons nos auditions que nous avons
commencé depuis 14h avec Cécile Duflot
sylvia Pinel Emmanuel cosse vous-même et
on terminera tout à l'heure avec
Emmanuel vargon sachant que la semaine
dernière nous avons auditionné François
de Rugy et Ségolène Royal donc vous avez
été député à partir de 2012 et vous êtes
devenu ministre de la transition
écologique de juillet 2020 à mai 2022
dans le gouvernement de Jean Castex l'un
des événements marquants de votre
ministère fut le vote en juillet 2021 de
la loi climat et résilience cette loi
avait vocation à reprendre et à incarner
les propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat qui avait été
lancé en octobre 2019 son titre 5 nommé
SeLoger comporte plusieurs dispositions
qui sont aujourd'hui au cœur des débat
sur la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments comme l'interdiction à la
location des passoires énergétiques vous
avez également mis en oeuvre le
remplacement du crédit d'impôt pour la
transition énergétique le cite par la
prime de transition énergétique mieux
connue sous le nom de ma prime rénove
l'ensemble des crédits d'évolue à ma
prime rénov à ainsi atteint 1,85
milliards d'euros en crédit de paiement
dans la loi de finances pour 2022 enfin
vous avez piloté les politiques du plan
France relance qui touche également à la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments il
faut aussi rappeler comme nous l'avons
fait à plusieurs reprises au cours de
nos auditions que les objectifs de
rénovation énergétique que nous étions
fixés je pense en particulier à la cible
de rénovation de 500 000 logements par
an ne sont pour autant jamais atteint
surtout ces sujets la commission
d'enquête souhaite connaître le bilan
que vous tirez de votre passage au
gouvernement quelles sont vos motifs de
satisfaction mais aussi peut-être vos
regrets et les sujets sur lesquels vous
auriez aimé aller plus loin quels sont
les difficultés auxquelles vous avez dû
faire face est-ce que le fait d'exercer
la tutelle sur le ministère du Logement
a été pour vous un atout et cette
nouveauté dans le découpage ministériel
doit-elle être conservée pensez-vous que
les propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat ont été
suffisamment reprises dans le projet de
loi climat et résilience la loi
aurait-elle pu aller plus loin ou au
contraire les mesures vous
semblent-elles rétrospectivement
inadapté
est-ce que les crédits qui ont été
consacrés à ma prime rénove vous semble
à la hauteur des enjeux et à ce sujet
quel regard portez-vous sur le budget de
2023 plus généralement ma prime rénove
fait l'objet de nombreuses critiques qui
portent notamment sur la nature des
travaux financés et sur les difficultés
que rencontre nos concitoyens pour
accomplir les démarches requises pour
pouvoir bénéficier justement de la prime
quel est votre position face à ces
critiques avant de vous laisser la
parole pour répondre à ces premières
questions dans un propos introductif
d'une quinzaine de minutes il me revient
de vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié je dois
également vous rappeler de manière
formelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
134-13
434-1 14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende voilà madame la
ministre je vous invite donc à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité à lever la main droite et à
dire je ne jure je le jure et bien je
vous laisse la parole pour une quinzaine
de minutes et ensuite notre rapporteur
ainsi que les membres de la commission
d'enquête qui sont présents dans la
salle ne manqueront pas de vous poser un
certain nombre de questions
complémentaires
je n'en doute pas merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur rapporteur mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrice et sénateurs
heureuse de me retrouver devant cette
commission d'enquête qui a le mérite en
plus de réunir des acteurs de la loi
climat résilience puisque vous je
reconnais un certain nombre de visages
de personnes qui se sont beaucoup
impliquées dans le sujet en premier lieu
vous madame la Présidente qui étiez
rapporteur sur ce fameux titre 5 sur
lequel vous avez presque plus de
connaissances que moi
je vais commencer mon mon propos
introductif pour vous resituer un petit
peu la situation quand je suis arrivée à
la tête de ce ministère
j'ai été nommée donc au début juillet
2020 avec effectivement une
évolution intéressante dans mon
ministère puisque le logement a été
intégré dans le périmètre le mystère et
ce qui me permettra d'ailleurs de
répondre à une question que vous avez
posée
c'était une évolution que je souhaitais
et que j'avais proposé à de nombreuses
reprises pourquoi parce que au-delà des
politiques traditionnelles du logement
on voyait bien que depuis un certain
nombre d'années et notamment évidemment
après la loi ltecv de 2015 la question
de la rénovation énergétique sur le
logement existant mais aussi la question
de plus en plus prégnante des règles
notamment pour le bâtiment neuf
avait des
comment dire des des connexions avec les
questions climatiques de plus en plus
fortes et la législation évoluée en ce
sens on était sur des cultures qui
n'étaient pas forcément des cultures
très communes et donc c'était très
intéressant de réunir sous un même
ministère les compétences climat et les
compétences logement il s'avère que ça
en plus était
un vrai plaisir de travailler avec la
ministre en charge du logement que vous
allez interroger juste après Emmanuel
wargon puisque tout ça nécessitait
évidemment une bonne coordination entre
nous et la coordination on peut le dire
a été parfaite même si et
l'honnêteté m'oblige à le dire
il y avait quand même dans les services
les directions des ministères des
cultures qui mettaient encore un petit
peu de temps à évoluer mais j'ose espoir
que notre travail en commun Emmanuel et
à moi a permis peut-être de faire
avancer encore cette évolution
nécessaire des cultures mais que l'on
croise dans d'autres ministères aussi le
logement est loin d'être d'être le seul
concerné et donc ça m'a permis dans le
cadre d'un ministère avec des
compétences absolument énormes de
pouvoir m'appuyer sur sur une ministre
qui
gérait seul
toutes les autres affaires concernant le
logement c'est à dire
l'accession à la propriété le logement
social toutes ces questions là et on
considérait qu'on avait une compétence
partagée sur ce qui concernait donc la
rénovation et tout ce qui était norme de
construction
quand je suis arrivée
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
venait quelques semaines auparavant de
rendre de rendre public ces propositions
ces propositions qui étaient donc au
nombre de 149 je vous ai rapporté
ce qui est ce qui était sur mon bureau
quand je suis arrivée donc qui est le
les normes recueil des propositions de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
dont je salue le travail parce que ça a
été un travail absolument incroyable qui
a été mis en place enfin par cette
convention je rappelle que
l'objectif de qu'on avait à signer assez
150 personnes qui étaient tirées au sort
de manière aléatoire
avec des techniques de manière à essayer
autant que faire ce peu de couvrir la
diversité de la population de la France
était de
trouver les alors je le dis de mémoire
il faudrait que vous retrouviez je
pourrais vous renvoyer le titre exact
mais en gros c'était de définir toutes
les mesures susceptibles d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 dans un
esprit de justice sociale donc en gros
et c'est ce que je dis souvent on a
demandé à ses citoyens de changer le
monde complètement on leur a demandé
quelque chose qui était absolument
énorme et ce qui explique d'ailleurs
qu'il y ait autant de propositions
ce qui a très bien fonctionné dans cette
dans cette convention citoyenne et c'est
un des enseignements que j'en retire
c'est que ces personnes qui pour
certaines étaient sensibilisées aux
enjeux climatiques pour d'autres pas du
tout ont réussi à adopter ensemble ces
propositions par consensus
alors que au départ c'était pas gagné du
tout qu'est-ce qui a fait que ils ont pu
arriver à ce résultat là c'est d'abord
qu'ils ont été sensibilisés très
fortement à la question climatique dès
leur première session qui a eu lieu fin
2019 qui est une session où ils ont
rencontré des scientifiques du GIEC et
notamment la maintenance très connue
Valérie massandelmotte ils se sont
enfermés avec elles dans pendant toute
une journée et ils vous le dirait
eux-mêmes si vous les interrogiez ils
ont reçu ce qu'on appelle une baffe une
claque et cette claque très forte
certains
il y a même eu des récits de pleurs etc
enfin quelque chose de très lourd a été
le moment
un petit peu décisif qui leur a permis
ensuite de se mettre au travail pour
proposer pour proposer leurs solutions
après un des plusieurs weekends de
travail en commun dont je vous rappelle
qu'ils ont été un peu interrompus à
cause de la crise covid de la covid donc
qui a fait que ça a pris du retard mais
malgré cela ils ont pu rendre leur copie
au président de la République
quand j'arrive le président de la
République les a reçu une semaine avant
à l'Élysée
les affélicités à juste titre pour leur
travail
et
Laura dit que il retenait sur les 149
propositions qu'ils avaient émises il en
retenait 146 donc si il s'octroyait
trois jokers qu'il considérait comme
absolument infaisable
et c'est Joker étant de mémoire sur le
préambule de la Constitution sur la
taxation des dividendes et puis le
dernier c'était sur les 110 km heure
en dehors de ça donc les citoyens
avaient compris
que le reste des mesures serait toutes
reprises
je pense que
cette situation de départ de fin ça
dépend de départ pour moi mais de fin
pour la convention citoyenne était une
situation qui en elle-même était
problématique
à partir du moment où le président
quelques mois plus tôt avait dit qu'il
reprendrait sans filtre les mesures
préconisées par la Convention citoyenne
pour le climat il avait mis un peu tout
le monde dans une situation impossible
inextricable pourquoi parce que les
citoyens du coup se sentaient à juste
titre
gardien de des mesures et quelque part
garant de leur mise de leur mise en
oeuvre de leur application
de l'autre côté les parlementaires à
juste titre pouvait se sentir des
saisies de leur rôle démocratique de de
de représentants du peuple et donc on se
retrouvait dans une situation où on
avait quelque part de légitimité qui se
qui se retrouvaient mise l'une en face
de l'autre alors que la convention
citoyenne avait au départ pour objectif
d'être une convention qui a porté des
propositions qui après devaient être
débattues et donc il a fallu gérer avec
les citoyens mais aussi avec les autres
représentants de notre société
c'est-à-dire toutes les corps
intermédiaires les syndicats les
représentants d'associations les élus
locaux par exemple il a fallu gérer de
faire cette intermédiaire entre eux et
des citoyens qui pour certains avaient
bien compris que il n'était pas possible
d'appliquer tout
d'autres
considérés que ce qui avait été dit par
le président c'était on reprend tout et
donc qui surveiller ligne à ligne si il
fallait comment il fallait appliquer
tout cela
donc quand j'arrive je reçois ça donc
c'est aussi pour vous dire que c'est
très bien qu'Emmanuel wargon viennent à
ma suite parce qu'Emmanuel wargon aura
certainement une expertise technique un
peu plus poussée que moi qui moi était
supposé prendre en charge tout cela
donc il y avait un certain nombre de
chapitres
donc le chapitre se loger donc qui
commence là et qui se termine
un peu plus loin jusque là jusqu'à se
nourrir donc vous voyez c'est ça dans la
convention citoyenne se loger qui est le
sujet qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
nous avons néanmoins décidé de reprendre
dans la préparation de la loi qui
s'appellerait plus tard la loi climat
résilience les
le découpage qui avait été fait par les
citoyens c'est à dire que eux avaient
découpé leur propositions en 5
thématiques donc qui était se nourrir se
loger se déplacer
se déplacer c'est dur de le faire de
mémoire
de nourrir se déplacer mais des pas vous
la connaissez tous mais c'est pas grave
produire et travailler
et je vous laisserai découvrir le
dernier mais en tout cas et se loger
voilà
nous avons décidé cela pourquoi parce
que justement nous
avions peut-être une possibilité de
faire une loi qui serait peut-être plus
agile en la découpant autrement mais on
se disait que pour la compréhension
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur de nos
concitoyens des membres de la Convention
citoyenne c'était plus simple de faire
comme ça et donc nous avons dessiné des
parties et qui permettait aussi de s'y
retrouver c'est à dire que les citoyens
pouvaient dire ben voilà là dans la
partie se loger c'est là qu'on va
retrouver les mesures législatives qui
correspondent à nos propositions c'est
ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs dans
l'ensemble
pour en arriver à l'élaboration de la
loi j'essaye de aussi de penser à vous
remettre ça dans le contexte plus global
les propositions se loger pour faire le
focus dessus sont des propositions qui
s'inscrivent dans une lignée de ce qui
avait été voté dans les années
précédentes
sachant que la loi un peu fondatrice
sur le sujet qui nous occupe et en
général
considéré comme la loi de 2015 la loi
ltecv
[Musique]
qui a été présenté par par Ségolène
Royal qui effectivement était une loi
assez fondatrice puisque d'abord c'est
la loi qui met en place
la SNBC la stratégie nationale bas
carbone c'est une loi qui
donne des objectifs de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
lance
c'est pas dans la loi mais qui lance en
dehors les programmations pluriannuelles
de l'énergie
elle crée les plans climats air énergie
cette loi est elle évidemment elle jette
les bases de ce qui va aujourd'hui être
notre socle pour la rénovation des
logements notamment en créant le cite le
crédit d'impôt pour la transition
écologique en
intégrant dans les critères de décence
là de décence d'un bâtiment la
performance énergétique qui qui permet
qui met un certain nombre qui pose un
certain nombre de bases qui ont été
ensuite réaffirmés dans la loi énergie
climat qui qui donc là est arrivé
5 ans plus tard en 2019 qui venait après
l'accord de Paris et qui nous mettait
dans la trajectoire de la neutralité
carbone à 2050 avec notamment la
création des plans climats donc on est
dans un
continuum d'une d'une trajectoire et
d'une dynamique qui a été lancée
quelques années plus tôt et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que justement le
regard des membres de la Convention
citoyenne pour le climat est un regard
très pragmatique c'est à dire qu'il
regarde
ce qui a marché ce qui n'a pas marché et
ils en profitent pour faire leur
proposition
leur proposition je pourrais les les
annexer peut-être aux réponses que que
je ferai à votre questionnaire mais il y
avait un certain nombre de propositions
on va dire un peu emblématique qui était
des propositions notamment de
d'interdiction de de location des des
logements qui étaient qui n'étaient pas
considérés comme
qui était en dessous d'une certaine
performance énergétique
en imposant un certain nombre de mesures
pour contraindre les propriétaires
occupants et les propriétaires bailleurs
à rénover de manière globale
ils sont beaucoup insistés dans leur
proposition sur cette notion de
rénovation globale qui effectivement est
un sujet très préoccupant puisque on a
constaté et ça a été constaté à
plusieurs reprises que ce soit par le
conseil pour le climat par la Cour des
comptes y compris par le Défenseur des
droits aussi d'ailleurs que les
rénovations qui existent en France et
qui était portée justement depuis les
lois que je vous ai citées étaient des
rénovations qui malheureusement étaient
ultra majoritairement des rénovations de
gestes simples c'est à dire on change
les fenêtres ou on isole sont son toit
ou on change une chaudière que sais-je
mais des rénovations qui ne permettaient
pas d'accroître la
la qualité globale de de son la
performance je vais chercher le mot la
performance globale du logement
donc ils font des propositions dans ce
sens
ils font des propositions aussi sur le
diagnostic de performance énergétique
ils font des propositions sur les
changements de chaudière à fioul
des propositions sur des des guichets
uniques ça aussi c'était un point
important qui avait été soulevé par
par les citoyens c'était sur la
difficulté d'accéder à une information
simple et unifiée sur tout le territoire
et de pouvoir accéder simplement enfin
toujours le terme simplement et de
manière pratique à des aides ce qui
avait été relevé par eux et à juste
titre parce que ça avait été aussi
relevé par les différentes études
c'était la complexité des
qui était apportée les trous dans la
raquette pour pour notamment les
copropriété par exemple et
le fait que du coup énormément de de
propriétaire
n'accédez pas ou accéder mal aux aides
qui pourtant existaient et prévu donc
c'est
évidemment avec une attention mais c'est
normal ça correspondait à leur mission à
une attention pour les plus démunis pour
l'accès aussi à ces aides pour les plus
les plus démunis et enfin ils avaient
fait des propositions intéressantes sur
la formation des professionnels du
bâtiment pour
répondre à la demande de rénovation
globale
voilà où on en est quand j'arrive
je
rencontre les membres de la Convention
citoyenne
nous préparons avec eux
la loi moi je les informe tout de suite
que dans cette
dans ce processus dans lequel nous
allons les associer même s'ils étaient
pas forcément
ils étaient partagés entre eux certains
considérer que leur travail était fini
d'autres considérés que et à juste titre
je pense que si on s'était nous-mêmes
investi dans un travail de d'aussi
longue haleine on aurait envie de
continuer un peu à participer à la suite
donc on leur a dit on vous demande pas
de participer par contre on va vous
tenir informé régulièrement de des
avancées dans la mise en oeuvre de votre
loi on a mis en place assez vite un
outil dont j'ai pu vérifier aujourd'hui
en allant voir par curiosité un outil de
suivi qui est qui existe toujours qui
est un outil de suivi de l'application
des mesures de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat donc quand vous allez sur
Internet que vous faites vous cherchez
sur un moteur de recherche suivi mise en
oeuvre de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat vous allez tomber très
rapidement sur le tableau qui prend
mesure par mesure la manière dont elle a
pu être appliquée ça a été difficile de
leur faire comprendre et de faire
comprendre d'ailleurs à tout le monde
que toutes les mesures ne se
traduiraient pas en mesure législatives
tout simplement parce que nous avons une
constitution qui nous dit que certaines
mesures relèvent de la loi et d'autres
non voilà donc certaines mesures n'ont
pas pu faire l'objet je pense par
exemple
opération fait l'interdiction des
terrassiophés typiquement ça fait pas
partie des mesures qui sont législatives
par contre elles ont fait l'objet de
mesurer réglementaires de la même
manière
il y a des mesures comportementales qui
sont difficiles à introduire dans une
loi il y a aussi des mesures là c'était
pas trop le cas sur se loger mais il y a
aussi des mesures qui relèvent de de
dimension internationales on a eu des
gros débats sur la question de l'écocide
par exemple
dont on voit bien que
on va pas faire une loi pour que j'aille
bolsonaro par exemple viennent répondre
de ce qu'il a fait sur la forêt
amazonienne devant un tribunal à
Poitiers ça n'a ça n'a pas de sens et
donc c'était des choses qui que certains
ont très bien compris que d'autres ont
un peu monté en épingle on va dire ça
comme ça
sur sur les mesures
se loger on a eu donc des échanges avec
les acteurs concernés que ce soit les
acteurs du monde du logement en général
que ce soit les collectivités que ce
soit les associations
de consommateurs
c'est
ça n'a pas été simple je réponds aussi à
des questions qui avaient été posées
dans le
dans le bâtiment dans le dans le dans
votre questionnaire
parce que justement
le problème entre guillemets de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat et
c'est aussi une leçon qu'on en tire
c'est que ils ont auditionné qui ils
avaient envie d'auditionner et ils ont
additionné beaucoup de monde mais
forcément vu encore une fois et je vu
l'ampleur des domaines qui étaient
explorés
il n'avait pas matériellement le temps
de rencontrer tous les acteurs concernés
c'était impossible et donc à partir de
ce moment là
eux ont fait des préconisations mais qui
ne rencontraient pas toujours
des contraintes que pouvait rencontrer
les acteurs concernés et c'est aussi ce
qui a été un sujet de frottement puisque
c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
n'ai pas pu reprendre de manière enfin
intégrale les mesures proposées même les
mesures qui étaient d'ordre législatif
parce que
quand vous avez un certain nombre
d'objectifs de rénovation de logements
c'est évidemment important de se
rapprocher de ce qu'il proposait puisque
ce qu'il proposait était pour le coup en
adéquation avec les objectifs
climatiques ça c'est vrai mais
il n'était pas forcément mis en
adéquation avec le nombre de personnes
qui étaient là pour pouvoir le faire et
donc nous notre sujet en tant que
responsable politique c'était de prendre
les objectifs qui étaient proposés par
la Convention citoyenne mais ensuite
d'essayer de les mettre en musique pour
que on puisse les appliquer le mieux
possible le plus proche possible de ce
qu'il disait mais de la manière la plus
pragmatique possible moi j'ai essayé
d'être pragmatique et donc
quand on a réfléchi à la mise en oeuvre
on n'a pas forcément réfléchi à une
rédaction qui montrer exactement à la
lettre mais par contre à une rédaction
qui collait à l'esprit et en essayant de
la rendre la plus opérationnelle
possible donc on pourra rentrer dans les
détails après si vous le souhaitez sur
le sur tel ou telle mesure je me
concentrerai sur une mesure qui pour moi
était absolument essentiel qui pour moi
devait répondre
à l'urgence
l'urgence pour moi c'était de trouver
une solution qui permette
à nos concitoyens d'avoir accès plus
facilement aux aides
et de s'y retrouver dans ce maquis
complexe des aides
c'était ça revenait tout le temps et je
pense que si vous messieurs évidemment
les sénateurs et sénatrices vous avez eu
à rénover votre logement à un moment ou
un autre vous voyez de quoi je parle il
s'avère que moi je l'ai expérimenté à
titre personnel et que même moi qui suis
quand même plutôt sensibilisée au sujet
j'ai pas réussi à avoir toutes les aides
auxquelles je pouvais prétendre et j'ai
loupé des trucs parce que j'ai mal
rempli enfin bon donc je me dis si même
quelqu'un de au courant comme moi
n'arrive pas à obtenir les aides vous
imaginez bien des gens qui n'ont pas la
même connaissance du sujet donc c'était
c'était assez énorme et donc nous avons
missionné pour nous aider dans la
préparation de ce qui me paraissait
vraiment être un sujet absolument
essentiel monsieur sechel qui a fait une
mission pour
justement essayer de trouver le meilleur
mécanisme pour répondre à cet objectif
absolument essentiel ça a mis un peu de
temps puisque la mission Sichel a rendu
ses conclusions alors que le texte était
déjà en cours d'examen au Parlement il
était déjà passé à l'assemblée du coup
le Sénat a pu
en tirer la substantifique moelle
mais cette mission a été très très bien
parce que ça nous a vraiment permis de
défricher de défricher les bases de ce
qui allait devenir la compagnateur rénov
qui a été intégré dans le texte dans le
texte de la loi dans le texte définitif
cet accompagnateur rénove pour moi c'est
la mesure
phare de de ce texte il y en a d'autres
j'aurais pu j'aurais pu parler de
l'interdiction de la location des
passoires thermiques avec les
différentes échéances qui nous a aussi
demandé beaucoup de travail mais cet
accompagnateur rénove pour moi c'est le
point
essentiel si on veut monter en puissance
sur les rénovations globales
pourquoi les gens font des rénovations
par gestes parce qu'ils ne savent pas
qui peuvent faire une rénovation globale
ils ne savent pas dans quelles
conditions ils savent pas comment ils
ont pas accès au diagnostic il y avait
des services publics de l'efficacité
énergétique dans certaines régions qui
étaient mieux développées que d'autres
c'était très inégalitaire illégal sur le
territoire je pense à la Picardie par
exemple notre Picardie je vois ici un
représentant de la Picardie avait mis en
place un service public de l'efficacité
énergétique qui était pas mal qui était
plutôt bien organisé qui s'est concentré
après sur les sur les copropriétés mais
qui avait le mérite d'être un peu
imprécurseur de ce qui va être
l'accompagnateur rénov donc mais il
était pas forcément très connu il avait
peu de moyens le problème c'est qu'il
gérait peu de trop peu de dossiers au
regard des besoins que nous avions et
c'était un des problèmes que nous avions
aussi c'était comment faire en sorte
pour que l'accompagnateur rénove ne
devienne pas un super spé mais
sans suffisamment de moyens pour pouvoir
faire face à l'ampleur de la tâche dont
vous avez rappelé les chiffres madame la
Présidente on devrait arriver à 700 000
rénovations par an je rappelle que nous
avons et ça c'est le rapport du Haut
Conseil pour le climat de 2020 qui le
dit si on veut atteindre nos objectifs
de de
l'accord de Paris on devrait atteindre
700 000 rénovations globales à partir de
c'est dans la SNBC 700 000 rénovations
globale aujourd'hui on est à 10 fois
moins même plus que 10 fois moins
donc on ne peut pas laisser simplement
des opérateurs publics gérer ça et donc
il faut mettre en place un système de
conventionnement qui est qui qui a fait
l'objet là d'un décret qui est sorti qui
est sorti récemment donc cette
accompagnateur Renov pour moi c'est ce
qui va permettre de faire avancer des
choses si il se met bien en place et si
tout cela est suivi des faits je vais
pas en dire beaucoup plus pour laisser
la parole à
vos collègues madame la Présidente juste
un point vous m'avez demandé un regret
je pense qu'en termes de moyens
on a donné beaucoup de moyens à la
rénovation
que ce soit sur les bâtiments privés
donc par le biais de ma prime rénov par
le biais d'essai de eux par le biais des
différentes aides publiques qui existent
on a donné des moyens aussi pour les
bâtiments publics dans le cadre de
France relance des moyens qui ont été
très forts en a fait 4 milliards sur les
bâtiments sur les bâtiments publics
néanmoins mon regret c'est que sur une
politique de cet envergure on aurait
besoin d'une loi de programmation
pluriannuel
du financement de la transition j'ai
même envie de vous dire pas seulement
sur le logement mais sur surtout et mon
regret c'est que on en est pas encore
peut-être en aura-t-il après la PPE
merci madame la ministre je passe la
parole sans plus tarder à notre
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la ministre pour vos explications
c'est vrai que vous avez assez bien
décrit du coup la situation
effectivement à laquelle vous êtes vous
êtes arrivés avec la convention
citoyenne pour le conscience citoyenne
pour le climat effectivement avec un
objectif fixé par le président de la
République qui était de 40% de baisse de
gaz à effet de serre sur l'horizon de
2030 et qui balayait très large puisque
c'était pas que le logement mais
effectivement il y avait tous différents
aspects petit aparté mais je pense que
s'il y a eu peut-être quelques rancœurs
ou voilà c'est plus le fait de pas avoir
atteint ces objectifs à travers la loi
quoi c'est-à-dire c'est 40% de baisse de
gaz à effet de serre et que en fait je
pense que les citoyens auraient
certainement compris le fait que on
reprenne pas tel ou telle mesure mais
qu'on la remplace par une autre je pense
que c'était plutôt dans ce dans ce sens
là et sur la question de la rénovation
la rénovation thermique c'est vrai que
ça a été dit par madame la Présidente on
a audition on va dire depuis 2012 les
différents ministres à la fois ministre
de l'écologie et puis ministre du
Logement bon déjà une petite question
sur vous en avez un petit peu parlé et
puis on verra madame wargon juste après
mais justement votre votre relation et
le lien entre entre les deux les deux
ministères alors dans votre cas c'est
vrai que le ministère du logement était
intégré mais ça peut être intéressant
voilà de voir quelle relation en tout
cas et de quelle manière vous avez pu
vous avez pu travailler après moi ce qui
m'intéressait peut-être et puis voilà il
y aura évidemment d'autres questions de
la part de mes collègues c'était c'est
vrai qu'en fait tous les je pense toutes
les personnes qu'on a pu additionner
jusqu'à présent nous ont dit à peu près
les mêmes mots c'est-à-dire il faut que
ça soit simple visible une porte
d'entrée
forcément une politique dans la durée et
des financements dans la durée donc
effectivement stabilité à travers une
loi de une loi de programmation
[Musique]
et en fait on s'aperçoit que ben on
dirait j'ai un petit peu cette
impression alors vous êtes dans les
dernières donc c'est pour ça que je fais
un petit peu ce cette rétrospective mais
un petit peu expression que chacun avait
la bonne idée quoi dire que on a mis en
place ça et ben c'était ce qu'il fallait
faire et c'était justement c'était
simple c'était efficace et puis ça n'a
pas duré et puis derrière on a on a
modifié on a un petit peu changé
etc quoi et là j'ai l'impression qu'on
revie un petit peu la même la même chose
j'ai l'impression que dans la loi de
2015 on avait des éléments déjà très
posés quoi à la fois en termes en termes
d'objectifs en termes de moyens aussi
avec le cite avec
avec l'appui l'appui de Lana
enfin voilà on avait on avait ces
différents dispositifs on avait aussi
quelque chose qui me paraissait
intéressant en 2015 qui était l'appui
quand même sur les collectivités c'est à
dire de mettre en place plutôt des
plateformes de rénovation énergétique
sur les territoires et du coup s'appuyer
plutôt sur ces territoires en termes de
proximité et d'accompagnement et
peut-être du coup de visibilité aussi
peut-être c'était en tout cas je dirais
pas mal de choses ont été mis en place
ont commencé à démarrer et puis c'est
vrai qu'on a l'impression que
on a un petit peu recommencé on a
rebaillé donc du coup arrêter le crédit
d'impôt donc ça ça me fait partie des
questions en fait entre la le ce choix
là d'arrêter le cite le crédit d'impôt
et de passer plutôt sur ma prime sur ma
prime rénov est-ce que c'est juste une
question de de visibilité en tout cas
qu'elle était vraiment la raison
derrière ce choix là parce que au bout
du compte c'est vrai que je pense que ça
a pas forcément clarifier en fait
vis-à-vis des gens qui voulaient faire
qui vous faire appel et puis l'autre
l'autre aspect vous avez parlé des
accompagnateurs rénov
qui moi me dirait une questionne un
petit peu parce que j'avais l'impression
dans ce qui avait été mis en place sur
les sur les territoires on avait un
petit peu déjà cette réflexion là de se
dire on a besoin d'avoir un
accompagnement d'avoir de l'ingénierie
de pouvoir avoir une analyse je dirais
bâtiment par bâtiment pour un
accompagnement vers du Bâtiment Basse
Consommation et puis peut-être de le
faire par étape en tout cas parce qu'on
sait qu'on peut pas toujours faire tout
ça d'un coup et puis là on crée ce
dispositif du coup d'accompagnateurs
donc plutôt dans le secteur privé en
créant plutôt un nouveau un nouveau
emploi on va dire une nouvelle une
nouvelle profession voilà ma question
c'était pourquoi ne pas s'appuyer en
fait sur ce qui existait déjà dans le
maillage territorial pourquoi pas le
développer même plutôt peut-être le
diversifier plutôt que recréer quelque
chose de nouveau avec peut-être le
risque et là c'est vraiment une
questionnement de se dire que si l'État
s'en charge si on met en place ce
dispositif là c'est vrai que les
collectivités etc risque aussi de faire
un petit peu marche arrière et de dire
bon bah c'est plus c'est effectivement
plus notre compétence donc les sons les
sons faire la politique nationale
et pour finir du coup ça me permet
justement aussi de d'ouvrir sur comment
vous voyez justement cette articulation
entre la place des territoires et je
dirais les politiques territoriales et
puis et puis cette politique nationale
où on a besoin de cette harmonisation et
donc peut-être sur cette question de
service public de la rénovation
énergétique vous en avez un petit peu
parlé mais est-ce que du coup ce serait
pas justement ce rôle là d'avoir ce
service public énergétique alors dans
les différents ministres qu'on a pu voir
certains nous ont dit que le contraire
c'était quelque chose qui est plutôt une
très bonne idée je crois que le premier
François de Rugy qu'on a vu nous a dit
par contre c'était une très mauvaise
idée et qu'il fallait
comment
d'avoir un service public de la
rénovation thermique et
du coup qui permettent justement de
d'appliquer en tout cas la politique à
l'échelle nationale et dans sa et dans
sa cohérence tout en s'appuyant sur les
sur les territoires
voilà Glo voilà globalement et puis je
serai des questions à mes collègues
merci
alors
tout d'abord pour répondre à votre
première question sur le lien entre les
deux ministères
ça renvoie plus largement aux problèmes
que rencontre le ministère de l'Écologie
de l'environnement enfin on l'appelle
comment il y a eu des
noms différents selon les périodes
en général
il y a un mot qui a la mode en ce moment
enfin une expression qui s'appelle la
charge mentale pas beaucoup de la charge
mentale et je trouve que ça s'applique
assez bien sur la question de du
ministère de en charge de l'écologie de
l'environnement
en gros traditionnellement c'est sur les
questions de climat sur les questions
d'environnement il y a eu une espèce de
tradition des autres ministères de
laisser la charge mentale de la
politique écologique du pays à ce
ministère et ça ça se traduisait de
manière assez évidente dans les fameuses
rimes les réunions interministérielles
que tout le monde connaît de nom en tout
cas qui sont des moments assez durs en
général pour les équipes du ministre en
charge de l'environnement parce que
c'est lui qui arrive en disant bah voilà
il y a telle ou tel objectif à respecter
et c'est cette voilà les mesures qu'il
faut mettre en place pour respecter cet
objectif et
traditionnellement tous les autres
ministères se liquent pour dire mais
c'est pas possible vous n'y pensez pas
il est à ce problème là ce problème là
ce problème là etc
et
ça il y a eu des évolutions je ne vais
certainement pas dire que rien ne se
passait et dans ces dernières années de
plus en plus de ministères et notamment
d'ailleurs avec l'arrivée du ministre de
Jean Castex à Matignon mais ça avait
déjà commencé avant Jean castèque
lui-même a impulsé dans les ministères
l'obligation de que chacun fasse ses
petites lettres pour expliquer ce qu'il
allait faire pour mettre en place des
mesures de transition écologique dans
son ministère donc ça a évolué mais
entre ce qu'il faut faire et puis la
culture a changé pas tout à fait la même
chose et alors que dans une rime on
devrait avoir ben voilà moi j'ai cet
objectif pour baisser les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et tous les
ministères si dans un monde idéal où
tout le monde portrait la charge mentale
tous les ministères arriveraient en
disant bah moi sur mon domaine de
compétences j'essaye de ne surtout pas
en citer pour ne pas créer de problèmes
mais dans mon domaine de compétence pour
arriver à cet objectif je pourrais faire
ça ça et ça et moi je pourrais faire si
je pourrais faire ça moi j'en ai été
témoin ça ne se passait pas comme ça
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois c'était
vous n'y pensez pas et donc on avait
tous les ministères contre le ministère
de l'Environnement et dans ce cadre
avoir le ministère du Logement intégré
dans le ministère de l'Environnement ça
changeait tout parce que du coup le
ministère du Logement prenait sa part de
la charge mentale
j'ai pas dit qu'il ne prenait pas du
tout avant je dis que là simplement d'un
point de vue institutionnel c'était ça
l'obligeait à le faire y compris avec
les directions des ministères qui se
retrouvaient à travailler avec toutes
les autres de manière beaucoup plus
serrée donc c'est en ça que c'était
intéressant donc pour répondre à votre
question et c'est aussi pour ça que je
me suis battue à la fin de mon exercice
ministériel pour que
ce soit la première ministre le Premier
ministre je savais pas encore que ce
serait une première ministre que ce soit
le Premier ministre qui prennent
abrahal corps cette charge mentale et
c'est pour ça que je suis ravie même si
après il va falloir que tout ça se
traduise des faits de manière
concrète on est au début d'un processus
mais je suis ravie que maintenant ce
soit la première ministre qui soit en
charge de la transition écologique que
il dit un secrétariat général à la
transition écologique spécifique qui
maintenant est supposée faire le travail
de d'un style cette charge mentale
partout
donc ça c'était la réponse à la première
question sur
l'arrêt du cite pour ma prime rénove
d'abord on avait un sujet du cite parce
que c'est un crédit d'impôt un crédit
d'impôt par définition même si on peut
avoir un chèque mais c'est quelque chose
qui
d'abord n'est distribué que l'année
d'après
donc on a un grand
[Musique]
pas entre le moment où on fait des
travaux et le moment où on peut
récupérer le crédit d'impôt pour un
certain nombre de ménages c'était
problématique parce que ils avaient pas
forcément la trésorerie pour le faire on
n'a pas résolu tous les problèmes avec
ma prime rénova j'en ai bien conscience
mais en théorie
la prime rénove permet très vite une
fois que les travaux ont été engagés de
pouvoir
lancer le processus pour pouvoir
recevoir la prime donc c'était quelque
chose qui se voulait plus proactif et
puis et puis ma prime rénove c'était le
cite mais c'était aussi d'autres aides
qui étaient fusionnées dans un dans ma
prime rénove donc on était sur vraiment
une opération de simplification alors
j'entends vos remarques monsieur
rapporteur sur le fait que chaque
nouveau gouvernement réinvente la poudre
ou réinvente
je suis pas sûre même si je vois ce que
vous voulez dire mais
finalement tout ça est assez récent
le lancement de des grandes opérations
pour rénover les logements les bâtiments
d'un point de vue législatif c'est 2015
on est en 2023 c'est récent
à échelle à échelle politique c'est
assez récent même si le SPECT dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de Picardie il
avait été mis en place bien avant mais
en Picardie on a toujours un petit peu
un peu en avance c'est comme ça donc
c'est assez récent et on doit aussi
tenir compte et c'est aussi le rôle
qu'on les parlementaire tenir compte de
des retours d'expérience et voir ce qui
a marché ce qui a pas marché clairement
les aides qu'on a mis en place étaient
trop compliquées trop trop lourd en
termes de de
d'accès
on pouvait pas faire comme si ça
n'existait pas et donc le fait de mettre
en place un guichet unique qui s'appelle
ma prime rénov avec un endroit unique où
aller chercher un site internet unique
où aller chercher c'était vraiment
l'idée de rendre ça beaucoup plus simple
et beaucoup plus accessible j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour dire que je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'on regarde de manière plus
plus clair sur le site aussi parce que
là j'y suis retourné par justement c'est
votre
votre réunion me permet m'a permis
d'aller jeter un oeil pour voir où ça en
été je pense qu'on a encore des
problèmes de de
d'accès parce que quand on va sur ma
prime rénov on n'est pas directement sur
France rénov hors France Renov c'est le
réseau justement c'est le réseau donc
c'est pas instinctif et mon
accompagnateur rénove que j'aime sur le
site ma prime rénov
il faut vraiment le chercher pour le
trouver et sur France rénov c'est pareil
on le trouve pas comme ça tout de suite
ce n'est pas proposé tout de suite moi
je crois que une des premières choses
qu'il faudrait faire c'est que sur ce
site
et après je parlerai des gens qu'on a au
téléphone mais sur ce site je pense
qu'il faudrait que tout de suite en
entrée de jeu y est cette proposition de
l'accompagnateur Renov il est
obligatoire d'accompagnateur Renov pour
certaines types de rénovations mais il
devrait être proposé tout de suite c'est
ça devrait vous avez besoin qu'on vous
aide à faire votre diagnostic PAF
directement ça aujourd'hui ça n'y est
pas et c'est c'est un peu dommage à mon
avis
sur sur le ce que vous disiez sur les
réseaux qui existent actuellement
comme je vous l'ai dit c'est pas à
l'échelle ce qui existe aujourd'hui et
très bien enfin il y a certains encore
une fois c'est inégal surtout sur des
territoires mais il y a vraiment
certains territoires où on a des des
systèmes qui sont bien et qu'il faut
saluer mais cela vont perdurer le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
pas à l'échelle du tout
on n'est pas à l'échelle pour pouvoir
faire 700 000 rénovations par an c'est
ça mon sujet et vous pourrez faire tout
ce que vous voulez j'ai fait les fonds
de tiroirs un des budgets et puis des
personnels publics de l'État ou des
collectivités on n'aura jamais assez de
monde compétent pour faire ça à
l'échelle donc si on veut passer à
l'échelle on doit recourir
on est tous dans le même bateau et on
est tous dans le même combat donc à un
moment on a intérêt à s'unir et à unir
nos forces là on a des des gens qui sont
compétents qui peuvent nous aider on a
par exemple des architectes on a plein
de professions qui peuvent nous aider la
question et de les conventionner
sérieusement c'est à dire de faire un
vrai travail de de convention de
conventionnement d'agrément pour que ils
puissent y avoir aussi cette
restauration de la confiance j'ai pas
employé le terme de confiance jusque
maintenant on a aussi un problème de
déficit de confiance beaucoup de nos
concitoyens se sont fait arnaquer
parce que il y a eu des
dans les différentes primes qui étaient
proposées
il y a eu des effets d'aubaine qui ont
permis à certains professionnels non
scrupuleux de s'attaquer à nos
concitoyens c'est aussi pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on a interdit maintenant
les appels téléphoniques sur la
rénovation énergétique le problème c'est
que beaucoup de considérés ne savent pas
donc il faut le redire que c'est
interdit et que si des personnes sont
sollicitées comme ça par téléphone il
faut qu'elle raccroche ou qu'elle dise
qu'elles vont appeler la police ou
qu'elles prennent les coordonnées de ces
gens pour prévenir les autorités
donc voilà c'est ça ma réponse c'est que
on a besoin de se mettre à l'échelle par
contre vous avez raison sur un point
très important c'est l'association des
collectivités d'ailleurs il est bien
prévu que l'accompagnateur rénove soit
agréée par l'État ou désigné par une
collectivité locale donc les
collectivités locales sont tout à fait à
même de organiser leur réseau
et je crois que c'est aussi
par ce biais là qu'on doit montrer qu'on
est capable entre l'État des
collectivités locales de de bien
travailler ensemble pour que le réseau
soit le mieux maillé possible pour que
tous nos concitoyens puissent y avoir
accès donc ça c'est c'est l'idée et
c'est la manière dont moi je vois les
choses pour que ce soit mis en place de
la manière la plus efficace
y a-t-il des questions de nos collègues
oui
alors madame la ministre on constate
depuis quelques mois une espèce de
dinadéquation des préconisations et des
dispositifs d'aide avec les principes de
rénovation du bâti qui a une valeur
historique ou architecturale mais qui
n'est pas protégé à ce titre les
vieilles fermes les maisons anciennes
dans dans les villages et hormis les
monuments historiques et les bâties qui
bénéficient d'une protection dans les
documents d'urbanisme tout est possible
pour ces maisons là par exemple de
l'isolation par l'extérieur sur du pan
de bois qui va qui va étouffer les
maisons
alors on constate aussi qu'en raison des
conclusions du DPE de nombreux
propriétaires de ce type de bien
renoncent à toute rénovation pour des
motifs financiers ou techniques ce qui a
pour conséquence l'abandon puis la
démolition de très nombreuses maisons
traditionnelles dans le cadre du zan des
études menées notamment par le cerema
par l'ADEME par la DREAL montre pourtant
et depuis 2011 que ce type de bâti est
moins énergivore que les constructions
qui datent de la seconde moitié du 20e
siècle et que sa réhabilitation
constitue d'un point de vue écologique
l'avenir de la construction puisqu'à la
différence de la construction neuve son
empreinte environnementale est faible
alors j'ai quelques questions à vous
poser
pensez-vous madame la ministre que le
nouveau DPE est adapté à tous les types
de bâtis je pense au mode de calcul mais
aussi aux qualifications du
diagnostiqueur
a-t-il été tenu compte des programmes de
recherche notamment de ceux du cerema au
moment de l'élaboration de la loi et
j'aimerais savoir aussi si votre
ministère a travaillé avec par exemple
celui de la culture qui est quand même
chargé de la protection de tous les
types de patrimoine en France ou alors
avec un ministère de l'Agriculture pour
pour développer on va dire des des
techniques de rénovation thermique
peut-être plus écologique plus le plus
local
merci
merci je sais pas si je
alors merci beaucoup pour pour ces
questions qui sont très importantes et
que je vous conseille si je peux me
permettre de vous donner un conseil de
poser également à Emmanuel vargon parce
que pour le coup elle s'est vraiment
elle qui s'est occupé de la réforme du
DPE de A à Z donc on a regardé ensemble
mais c'était vraiment elle qui était aux
manettes sur le sujet
bien sûr quand on a réfléchi à la
réforme du DPE mais pas seulement
d'ailleurs aussi quand on a réfléchi à
d'ailleurs la nouvelle réglementation
pour le pour les logements neufs on a
réfléchi à
d'abord à
essayer de repenser les qualifications
en repensant à des techniques
traditionnelles je crois que les
techniques traditionnelles ont été un
peu oubliées alors pour des raisons
simples c'est parce qu'on avait une
énergie bon marché et que donc ça
coûtait rien de de fabriquer des
logements qui étaient des passoires mais
on oublie que l'habitat traditionnel est
un habitat qui en général plutôt bien
adapté alors traditionnel avant les
années 50 et plutôt bien adapté aux
situations locales puisque c'était une
période où il fallait pas gâcher
gaspiller l'énergie donc
on a beaucoup à apprendre de nos anciens
de la même manière il y a eu un gros
travail qui a été fait sur
l'identification des des
de techniques et de et de matériaux qui
sont des mathés qui sont des matériaux
soit biosourcés
soit des matériaux dont qui étaient
regardés à l'aune de leur efficacité
énergétique et y compris aussi à l'aune
de leurs émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a eu
mais là je parle beaucoup plus sur sur
la question de l'aérone mais on a eu
beaucoup de difficultés avec le secteur
du béton qui considérait qu'on donnait
trop de place à
la filière bois d'une manière générale
mais parce que en termes de mission de
gaz à effet de serre on est sur on est
sur vraiment des choses très différentes
les programmes de recherche du Serena
ont été regardés ça j'en suis persuadée
mais vous demanderez encore une fois
confirmation à
Emmanuel wargon je ne voudrais pas dire
de bêtises à sa place les travaux avec
les autres ministères oui d'une manière
générale pas seulement sur ça mais ils
ont été
associés sur sur la loi climat et
résilience et sur cette partie se loger
évidemment après les ministères
étaient aussi proactifs mais il venait
nous voir
dois-je le dire publiquement mais
il venait plutôt nous voir pour nous
dire ce qui les embêté
dans la loi enfin je soyons clairs je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de la charge
mentale on a on avait des ministères
franchement ils ont tous essayé de jouer
le jeu
et je les salue en cela mais ils étaient
quand même sur un certain nombre de
sujets un peu
en fait à devoir lutter contre la
culture de leur ministère au départ
parce que moi je connais pas beaucoup de
ministères qui intégré la transition
écologique dans leur fondamentaux au
départ
et donc ça a été moi qui suis une
indéfectible optimiste on va dire que ça
a été un moyen de
de les sensibiliser encore plus et de
les faire participer sur la question de
moi je pense que ce que
les problèmes que vous avez mentionnés
sur le fait que on puisse favoriser par
exemple de l'isolation par l'extérieur
sur des bâtiments non protégés parce que
c'est pas des bâtiments historiques
parce que ou alors parce qu'ils sont pas
dans un périmètre de bâtiments
historiques
c'est un sujet problématique qui à mon
avis peut être résolu justement par la
compagnateur rénov pour moi il y a eu
beaucoup de bêtises qui ont été faites
parce que
quelque part les personnes n'avaient pas
connaissance des alternatives qui
étaient possibles quand on a des belles
maisons avec effectivement des pans de
bois etc il y a d'autres moyens de les
isoler ou en tout cas de leur donner une
meilleure performance énergétique que
forcément leur mettre un revêtement
absolument atroce devant enfin c'est
c'est évident mais ça ça ne peut se
faire que si on a des gens formés pour
ça et ça c'est un des autres problèmes
c'est que on a toute la filière à mettre
en ordre de marche derrière
donc il y a des mesures qui ont été
prises sur la formation sur la mise en
branle de la filière mais on n'est pas
encore au bout loin de là et
l'accompagnateur ne peut fonctionner que
si derrière on a aussi des artisans qui
sont en capacité de proposer des
produits qui soient qui soit adapté et
qui est en qui est derrière où en amont
toute la filière qui permette aussi de
donner les matières premières
nécessaires pour que les artisans
puissent faire leur travail c'est ça
aussi que n'avait pas forcément vu de
manière globale la convention citoyenne
pour le climat
ils avaient pensé à la formation des
professionnels mais
pas forcément à toute la chaîne de
valeur ouais la structuration de la
fille et une structuration de filière
c'est long alors le problème c'est que
il faut qu'on réduise ce temps le plus
vite possible enfin le plus le plus
possible parce que pendant ce temps-là
le climat continue de se réchauffer
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a mis des
dates notamment sur les sur la
l'interdiction de location dépasseoirs
thermiques parce que
sans date sans échéance et ça fait
partie des débats oh là là mais sans
date sans échéance
c'est compliqué de d'y aller quoi donc
moi je préfère qu'on ait des échéances
bien claires dans la loi que tout le
monde sache qu'elles seront respectées
et derrière ça permet à la filière aussi
d'avoir une visibilité vous parliez tout
à l'heure de visibilité c'est important
aussi d'avoir une visibilité donc ils
ont une visibilité en terme législatif
maintenant ce serait bien qu'ils aient
une visibilité pour pour les aides
merci beaucoup madame la ministre merci
à vous et puis on vous souhaite une un
bon début de soirée puisqu'on est en fin
de journée merci à vous merci beaucoup
non on a encore Emmanuel